but the way you talk about marriage and
and how people that are not into signing
up for a bad deal are basically uh
[__]
makes me laugh
um I think it's more so
Jordan Peterson
that Drew that conclusion in the
three-part series that you had to pay to
watch on The Daily wire which is linked
in the description below I I dealt with
that earlier in the year in the last 12
months anyway but the link is below in
the description if you haven't watched
it you should watch it
the entire series you know the entire
three-part series that Jordan Peterson
puts out talking about marriage is
essentially man up don't be a wimp don't
be hedonistic
um take your vows
um
all that stuff point and sputter
basically
um let me see here I had a DM from a
friend on uh Twitter the other day
he was talking about he was asking me
about the daily wire thing I'm not going
to mention his name but he's very
popular name you know who he is uh he
said Jordan's a crybaby
uh let me see here
so one of the points that he made which
I thought was interesting because
you know these these traditional
conservative guys are like do as I say
right this works do as I say this works
do it do it now do it now right sort of
thing
so
one of the things that he pointed out
which I believe is absolutely true
because he experiences is
99 of women who were to get sick let's
say something like cancer because I
think Jordan Peterson's wife got
extremely sick when married to a man
don't want the kind of man who spirals
down into a drug addiction which he did
because he had to go to was it Russia to
try to fix this I think is what
Michaela's former husband brought them
to Russia to deal with when she needs
them the most most
and he says this guy's very lucky to
still be married to her
so anyway there's that
um you're in my view I think you're
going to see these daily wire guys
because they're in mostly recent
marriages like within the first 10 years
let's see them all get to 20 years all
right let's see if their wives stick
around for 20. let's see if any of them
untie the knot and I will admit that
they have a much higher probability
of having a successful marriage over a
long period of time because the daily
wires is a successful influential
platform it's a conglomerate it's a
group of a lot of these traditional
conservative guys and gals um what's her
name is it Candace Owens she used to be
red pill black she pivoted you know she
did her own thing red pill black and
then she hopped on The Daily wire
um
you know this conglomerate of all these
guys
um and and gal I I think have legs
because they're all trying to keep the
family strongly religious adhering to
the principles of the protocols whether
it's Judaism or Catholicism or whatever
happens to be they're all going to be
very successful in the coming years
um there's an appetite for what it is
that they're talking about
anti-wokeness anti-transgenderism like
the stuff that's counter-intuitive uh to
like the progressive message which most
people are getting you know fed up with
it's crammed down everybody's fruits so
I agree with the vast majority of what
they're saying it's just when they get
to stupid areas that it's just man up
and don't be a [__] it's like look you
guys are all multi-millionaires you're
all successful you're all
um drawing the attention and eyeballs of
a large audience and we know that women
like you know successful men that are
doing something with their lives putting
a dent in the universe that have the
attention of people where men want to be
them and women want to be with them sort
of thing like they have some anxiety
around it so I think the chances of them
having
success over a very long term is
probably greater than the average Joe
okay the average Joe watching their
stuff uh doesn't have the same chances
of being that successful
uh the average Joe are more than likely
to be part of the stats that end up in
the divorce stats or end up in a crap
marriage where
um there's no love you know between the
two parties uh there's disgust I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out